how's it going good citizens of the reject
Nation we are back I am back it is 2023 and
we are gonna watch Justice League War because
of how much we enjoyed Flashpoint and how
much you seem to enjoy us enjoying that movie
we read the comments and the comments seem
to say hey this is a whole series you know
what's next Justice League War and we're like
you know I like a good series and maybe we'll
watch even more of them if you hit that subscription
Bell so you can get notified if we do in fact
watch from the program for them but hit that
likes we know to watch more of them how you
doing Greg I was just thinking
Greg that was for you how you doing John I
am terrific I'm ready to step over to the
dark side because it started a dark universe
and we're going to some sort of War I'm better
I can hear more than I've been able to hear
since Thanksgiving uh I am propped up on all
sorts of like energy and more energy to come
now speaking of more energy if you want to
watch this full thing synced up with more
energy than you can imagine become a sexy
reject by becoming a patron and you can watch
this whole shebang because we're watching
on HBO Max that's really accessible so you
just line it up sync it up press play whole
ship bang I think we are ready hit that like
leave a comment let's go to war
[Music] is this the mysterious Batman who's
been spotted in Gotham
whoa that stands to reason I mean I buy it
[Music] what is happening going somewhere
buddy all right you want to dance let's dance
he does have a Frank Miller Batman shape to
him
Green Dragon Lantern your move precious no
no don't oh
nice it's an elevator these movies can be
so good make a Green Lantern movie good What's
it gonna cost me you're welcome lady come
here now I ain't falling for that Hal Jordan
knows better
food
high-tech armor huh you're gonna have to do
better than that oh
damn like a skip Stone okay that was better
thank you real Batman what were you doing
at the Docks I want answers
these anime movies do not mess around they
just go
Green Lantern Express so badass in this
take your glow stick and go home Gotham's
mine
[Music] no see this entire space sector is
my beat
[Laughter] love the imagination of these things
so good Witnesses spotted this thing trying
to plant some kind of bomb downtown when the
cops confronted it it spewed fire from its
mouth Green Lantern can do anything except
shut up apparently wow someone forgot to take
their True Blood tonight ah topical I don't
have HBO it's been canceled
oh crap that's a bomb and he just armed him
wait oh yeah
[Laughter]
it's a nice tribute to Batman Forever it doesn't
scan like a bomb more like an alien computer
like the guy in Metropolis Superman his power
levels are not gonna be a problem for me
it's broadcasting some kind of signal and
we've tracked similar signals emitting from
coast city Gotham and Metropolis then it's
talking to someone it's trying to create some
kind of unity any further data on the device
I'll catch up with you later Dr Stoner the
safe just calm flash over the phone like yeah
I'm like I don't feel like that phone is safe
come on man be a dad don't let him become
cyborg you're messing up
come on
and one for your grandson what
you are not silent yourself go out on a limb
[Music]
a man [Applause] next up Nationals Sports
and hard making some plays yay
I don't know you kid dad dude on my dad these
freaks cost America
who's gonna pay for that us regular people
that's who I know what channel news he watches
that's Grim what is your problem with me you
swing that sword with a smile and you scare
normal people and you dress like all wow my
guy Jesus the lasso compels you now tell us
your truth I cross-dress in a Wonder Woman
outfit it makes me feel powerful live for
truth buddy come on we don't King shave in
this house no not at all Embrace Your Truth
yeah Diana gets it through this touchdown
pass like 4 . doesn't matter if there's not
someone on the other end to make the catch
must be nice to trust someone else that much
just wish I could trust my dad I should go
nice meeting you Victory tell your dad he's
got some great seats yeah I will oh I think
he would love to know this cold Asher Angel
where's my [Laughter]
that's close I've been tracking his flight
path on what your own satellite
I love this Batman they're great do they get
paired up a lot I love them together when
they do it's always great I'm liking it this
is a good move first one to the building is
I really hate that guy nah you learn to love
him no offense let's get in the way
Superman's ass TMZ's got the video topical
I'm a lawyer
those are Superman laser oh no
right through the cell so
what can you do interesting the creature that
attacked me had one of those boxes you have
all right now let's start if I would actually
go like he's just pushing forward this is
great like there's no reluctance round two
flyboy
Lantern no wow
he's pissed off we have to talk to him
yeah use your words boys should have started
there maybe I don't know
you bruised but you don't kill dude Clark
that's cool hahaha Bruce Wayne oh who the
hell is Bruce Lee
this is great
oh yeah yeah we are in danger of losing the
element of surprise my Lord I humbly ask that
you move up your timetable Let The Invasion
begin oh wow did we get Granny Darkness what's
happening we are witnessing the birth of a
new race of superhumans beings who can fly
tear through buildings and outrun race cars
they will make what you can do obsolete wow
World throwing a football is a joke wow father
of the year you're never gonna go to one of
my games are you no wow what's happening we
can talk about this later the times that you've
left I don't know I'm not really gonna talk
yeah that's kind of that's it you said no
you just cut directly to the chase you might
be staring down the barrel of a full-scale
Invasion you're paranoid let's just crack
it open and see what happens sure without
any idea what's inside that is idiotic I'll
show you idiotic oh
I'm trying to lock in on the signal now this
thing is more important to you than your own
song oh you've done it it's gonna blow
uh oh
oh cool Mobile Suit Lantern exactly Gundam
Lantern [Music]
oh
ouch
we need to get out of here now which way we
have to get him into the Red Room to turn
him into a sexy spy it's inevitable
for the
first time I won't leave you
Dad yes Victor I'm here it's not gonna be
easy but ah it's eating him from the inside
out he's going into cardiac arrest it's racing
up his spinal cord [Music]
even animated that hurt sound design I've
taken apart and rebuilt most of it it can
save my son's life it has to
no
he's in pain I'm it would seem [Music]
s going the other way oh I didn't notice that
that's cool yeah
recalibrating memory
what's happening stay calm son
better be an important phone call
s
it's kovic
whoa offensive mode activated
blue 42 starts
foreign
[Music]
I was wondering how they're gonna chip away
at it that's cool I mean I feel bad for him
but yeah but it's a great detail [Music]
[Music]
as quick as I could what noise Cannon enabled
whoa [Music] it's a good Discovery after all
them yeah
that's how you fight Batman
[Music] nice there's too many of them just
to Barrel through yes oh that's a Superman
wow that's it smile for me wow
yeah swing away hey
[Music]
sweet oh it looks just like a McGinnis drawing
that's dope
over cautious huh we'll be fine [Music] [Laughter]
I need eyes
wow [Applause] [Laughter]
[Music] yeah Diana she got that meeting after
all Wonder Woman goodness yes
[Music] oh yeah but now you're on that plane
just uh oh
sweet shot yeah some Iron Man 3 action yeah
what's happened to me your mind is now a quantum
computer Sun there's buzzing in my ears make
it stop oh half man half machine you had to
make it just another one of your experiments
don't you hear the buzzing oh well thick I
empathize you know what I think I am needed
downtown clearly need to talk so
commencing Paradigm and indoctrination download
initiated whoa
translating command locate inhabitable worlds
oh werewolf by night we've only just met you
oh no thank you Clockwork Dark Side didn't
need that at all repurpose organic materials
para demon
[Music]
oh
dude always too soon Hal looks like you could
use a hand flash my boy great to see you
oh yeah and that's Batman 's real yeah he's
over there [Laughter] favorite line it's over
there it's not for a delivery get ready here
they come
hi
Boogie hi
incoming no [Music]
I can vouch for that he was at Star Labs oh
thank God Barry hey there what's up Shazam
I'm with him didn't turn back right yeah you
have to shout it I've talked to their technology
they're terraforming the Earth how do you
figure well for one thing the water's on fire
oh no oh that's bad
they're very ominous they're all Sauron eyes
this isn't an isolated incident either it's
happening across the world we're too late
he's here oh no yeah
Omega beams Green Lanterns got this dude
that's a dead Lantern
is that your boyfriend no cool watch this
Blackheart the Death Eater or whatever your
World of Warcraft name is
wait no
no oh boy we're gonna have to move fast not
a problem for me
yeah Flash and Superman are kind of racing
right now yeah they got a little moment flash
is winning as he should
oh smart
never had to catch my breath before [Laughter]
oh no oh a full skeleton there and we saw
the inside of Kal-El finally the Kryptonian
is ours Master will be pleased we flew off
with him I saw it they took Superman I'll
get him Lantern dude Lantern please my name
is Bruce Wayne when I was 10 my parents were
murdered in front of my eyes spent my life
trying to fight the same sort of criminals
that took them from me this is different if
this isn't about me you're telling me this
why we won't win without our big gun where
the hell are you going
I'm going to get Superman cool
[Music]
foreign
prepare a demon in the service of a dark side
does that guy decide I assume but I've never
seen him look like bizarroy it's just a dark
side said so once we have our champion he
will seize the other supers and bring them
as well
Clockwork Kryptonian nope nope nope nope get
him out of there his showboating is gonna
ruin the entire plan oh great now I'm Batman
foreign
wouldn't you
dude
come out as a team as a team
nice
damn [Music]
well now it's all blown up hopefully you're
good there
foreign
sludge blood dark side
we only got one more eye
come on Justice League foreign
's weakness kidneys
sweet
[Music]
flash take out the other eye come on yeah
I need this to save the world thanks for your
help
I love his delivery too he's always like talking
a little fast Flash is solid flashlight
[Laughter] [Music]
the world needs Clark Kent the world needs
his journalism Intrepid reporter both eyeballs
blown out and he's still stands we do try
and send him home
with a note to his mama bad boy they're creating
portals boom tubes I just have to speak their
language I didn't understand it
let's do this video Network too many pop-ups
ad blocker ad blocker oh no oh I guess it's
good the void peers back into you
oh cool oh nice effect [Music]
damn that's rad
that's actually pretty scary blind and just
sudden around oh [__] whoa
I don't care nice [Music]
yeah nice yes
unable to connect damn it dude oh
that was awesome
oh good fall great call
[Music]
come on [Music] closure
yeah nice don't tell him okay it's none of
their freaking business it'll be our secret
I always said
[Laughter] nice job kid where'd Shazam go
he took off he said he had a hot date right
who'd go out with that immature Hot Head human
victims let me just get this baby to Boom
for me one more time
yeah oh I love the catcher's mitts we should
leave before they blame us again oh all done
thanks for not talking about the other thing
don't sweat it and thanks for seeing me in
here oh you're the bomb Victory I know I know
you keep reminding me victory victory what
if something like this should happen again
please what could possibly happen that said
oh no I'm very pleased to introduce to you
do you guys have a name yes we do you can
call us the super seven oh no [Laughter] you
don't like it how about just the seven yeah
I think that works out well this type of team
this dynamic it's a nice little subversion
though they dance around the word League yeah
yeah so the Jeff John Jim Lee so like new
52 I think this is what this is based off
of I I wasn't reading a lot of DC the new
52 era I think this is based on but it's like
really different I was gonna ask are the the
characterizations seemed a bit more like spunkified
almost yeah it's definitely like a a little
Sean Aston Michelle Monaghan huh Shamar Moore
Alan Tudyk is not who I would expect it as
Superman damn all right D Bradley Baker Ian
cruffled Mr Fantastic was Thomas Morrow ah
Mercer hey not bad that's awesome and we know
there there's a post credits we'll probably
you know chitty chat a little bit but we will
get to the post credits scene so stay tuned
for whatever if you're all synced up whatever
version you guys are watching yeah but yeah
like looking at the characterizations like
I really enjoyed them but I wasn't quite expecting
it definitely isn't like and and you know
every Arc every uh like there's a reason the
crisis has happened like the DC Universe reboots
itself like really often so when the crisis
has happened like it's a new universe um some
of them I like some I don't um personally
like just personally and this is gonna people
are gonna be mad in the comments but I I didn't
enjoy about half and I didn't enjoy half
oh what's the next threat I was wondering
where Aquaman's been this whole time literally
like spiers in the sea I'm like
oh oh [__] Master the surface dwellers
have killed our King this is an act of war
and they will pay
oh there's our next threat oh damn fighting
the sea got some Ocean Master shenanigans
uh what so you're I mean more aware of the
movie side than the than the comic side what
did you think of the characterizations I mean
I really I I enjoyed the I enjoyed them for
being a little bit off the beaten path yeah
but not extremely so but at the same time
I was aware throughout that at least some
of the characterizations were a bit just a
bit different than especially like Superman
and Wonder Woman were a bit different than
what I associate with classic yeah I don't
have as great of a Hal Jordan reference point
although I remember people saying that Ryan
Reynolds was like a bit too snarky for Hal
Jordan and that's the thing for me is like
Hal Jordan isn't Kyle Rayner or Guy Gardner
so those are two other lanterns yeah and and
like I Kyle Rainer is my favorite Lantern
because he's all about creativity because
he makes more ornate crazy things like with
his Lantern power and they leaned that way
with some of the snark and his power use but
Guy Gardner is kind of a dick and they kind
of added that to him too so this hell felt
like three of the different lanterns and that
made him kind of feel like diluted because
he was he was three of them like to me that
makes so like I didn't really like identify
with this how like it doesn't feel like hell
to me but it's more interesting than some
of the takes on hell because he's very stoic
and a little bit more rigid in some takes
but like to me that wasn't really how Jordan
um but the Wonder Woman thing like I did not
like this one like that I didn't mind Green
Lantern but Wonder Woman would never say like
it's good to be back in the heat of War like
she also wouldn't threaten people like she
likes Humanity like she wouldn't go around
like causing problems and she was like hot-headed
and childish and that's not that childlike
is Diana like the scene on the boat is Diana
because she's learning about the world with
open eyes and an open heart childish is judging
and like swinging a sword around and being
immature like there's a big difference yeah
and obviously you're much more an expert than
I but I associate Diana with being a bit more
poised and yeah having a bit more awareness
of everyone around and concerned and yeah
just like being I think that's a great distinction
childlike versus childish she's she's Regal
but childlike this was arrogant and like a
despot like like you know she didn't she didn't
like I wouldn't want to have a meeting with
the mascara if this was their Regent like
it just felt very hot-headed yeah yeah I can
I can get on board with that it's like I found
it using as uh I did enjoy it as a take and
I thought that the type of character can Merit
this but at the same time it was perhaps the
most uh sort of not distracting but noticeable
departure for me so that was pretty distracting
for me yeah I was like I'm enjoying this I'm
amused by this but also I could see how this
isn't necessarily definitive uh and could
you know yeah potentially betray some of the
spirit of the character when like what I thought
was the voice acting was good work but then
the lines weren't the character so like I
I very much noticed it as soon as she showed
up I was like oh this voice works fantastic
it feels powerful it sounds like what I think
Diana would sound like I'm a huge Michelle
Monaghan fan didn't realize it was her until
the end and then I was like oh that tracks
yeah but I think the portrayal of her acting
wise could have been great but the the writing
and the and the way they wrote the character
like none of that's Diana like there wasn't
a single scene that I was like that's that's
Wonder Woman Like That quintessential yeah
and like then Superman he's so so for me Green
Lantern's like half and half and Superman's
like half and half and Wonder Woman's completely
wrong to me but again this different take
but this almost felt like an else world this
felt more like an other world Batman is perfect
Batman spot on I loved Batman and this is
the Batman you need in like when James Gunn
rewrites the universe Pattinson should stay
over there in my opinion and a Batman like
this should be the one that interacts with
these characters yeah a more seasoned Batman
and a Batman who has been doing this long
enough to have like a mild humor about it
yeah there's got to be a little bit of like
tongue-in-cheek like I'm a guy in a bat suit
whereas the Reeves universe that's not what
the character is so you you won't like that
won't work in a comedic I'm aware of how weird
this is the way yeah and I I just feel like
Superman like there's something about some
creators that just want to make Superman evil
like I don't know what it is like they just
like he's always like on the edge and so like
when he killed that dude I'm like well that's
just one step away away from snapping zod's
like everyone just wants to homelander them
and the reason homelander works is because
it is so opposite like the reason homelander
like it's reacting to yeah so if if he's even
10 closer to homelander it negates both of
them sure I did have that thought it's another
Wonder Woman moment but I did have that thought
in the plane of like thank God this Wonder
Woman is like at least on the good side of
this fight otherwise this could turn into
a boy's situation and yeah this this very
much felt like they those two characters could
turn and I don't think that's the characters
like he doesn't go you know arrogantly you
know you're welcome to Batman like Batman
is snarky but like Superman doesn't rub it
in people's faces that he has more Powers
that's why he's super is because he's not
proud of his abilities he has a responsibility
yeah yeah I can I can definitely see where
you're coming from with that and and it didn't
bother me but but like I said it was certainly
noticeable like I enjoyed like for me I enjoyed
this front to back oh I had a fun time but
I had to make an US World else World up here
yeah and then that was the thing is is and
and we'll get to you know all the the juicy
plot stuff but that was the thing coming out
of the previous movie because everyone's like
oh this this is the next one and I guess that
communicated to me the idea of like okay this
is gonna flow directly continuation and that
one I loved loved like that was like a Phantasm
good I was I was a little worried because
I'm so excited to watch this whole journey
and like as long as you know people keep wanting
to have us watch these I wanted to but this
felt like Flashpoint to me was an A plus Phantasm
level genre redefining I'm like overwhelmed
and this I had to reread it as an elseworld
and I and this was more of like a c for me
like not gonna lie like I really I struggled
and maybe it's personal because we're going
through this reboot of DC and I keep reading
about people that just fundamentally disagree
with who Superman is to me and what worries
me is I'm always worried I'm the one that's
wrong and I know every character is archetypal
every character has interpretation sure but
I have so much comic book data as well as
like reasons behind why Superman can't be
like this and then I see things like this
and I'm like well this is why these people
all think that's Superman because that's what
people are making so I'm worried if someone
makes something in this vein it's it's falling
down that same problem and again what if I'm
wrong what if this is Superman yeah and I
feel like the animated movies lend more Credence
to the idea that something would be presenting
itself as comic book authenticity exactly
like that more so than the automatic I think
handicap you give a live-action movie of like
well they're gonna change that they have to
adapt it's a movie yeah yeah and I mean this
was this was cool in in a way to you know
like we just had the Snyder cut and we've
had you know lots of inspiration come out
out of this story for you know the live-action
DC movies we've seen recently and so it was
really cool to watch the counterparts in this
iteration and and like I said yeah in terms
of performances and characterizations I really
enjoyed watching everyone together yeah the
last fight dude like I kept saying during
like that was Jackie Chan yeah like they did
the thing where it's like why aren't they
all attacking ones oh they are dark side's
that good but the way they choreographed that
fight like dark side was perfect okay positives
Dark Side uh I I really enjoyed flash yeah
uh I really enjoyed Shazam I think they did
a great job with Billy and Shazam Shazam and
Cyborg both yeah both as individuals and together
I really like and they gave them time I really
enjoyed that this gave cyborg time cyborg
is still the heart it was still yeah literally
because that is one thing about about this
that did surprise me is is like I said I I
very much enjoyed watching and I had a blast
but given what a significant Arc it is what
a significant villain and story it is it it's
funny looking at Flashpoint Paradox that gets
straight to the point and it doesn't feel
like it's short or anything like that or like
it's lacking in any substantial element whereas
this does get kind of right to the point and
you pretty much just watch them deal with
yeah it almost feels like a big act 3 movie
because we don't meet Bruce Wayne really we
have a reveal we have a conversation we never
meet Clark yeah and there's certain things
that are like the the beauty of superheroes
is they have to balance their other lives
and if you don't have their other lives come
to play at all you notice it yeah like Hal
Jordan's got four seconds on screen but he's
just out of his like there's no human element
and that's literally just to like clarify
for us in the back like okay it's house and
then Batman to reference it later yeah so
like I I just feel like uh we didn't get the
people behind the heroes in this yeah I liked
the the like ending idea of you know touching
on like the gods it's nice to be among a Pantheon
again and sort of directly checking who some
of these Inspirations are but yeah I guess
I you know in my armchair criticism I could
have used yeah just maybe a little more like
this is a tight you know 80 minutes or so
I I could have you know I would have gladly
sat for another 10 or 15 to get yeah a little
more of the life of the characters because
two if it was just directly feeding out of
the last movie and like voice casting aside
like that's one thing but yeah yeah just like
the overall characterizations felt like I
was watching a new movie with a new set of
interpretations and so yeah you don't have
the previous movie then to fall back on whereas
at the start you kind of feel like maybe you
could uh because yeah and like Flashpoint
Paradox you still do get at least a little
bit of the personal side of things and especially
through Barry Allen obviously because of how
personal that story is but yeah like as as
just a swath of of sort of action and you
know characters all pointed towards a single
convergence Point like yeah I thought it was
thrilling and fun and well directed but yeah
I mean not as big of a slam dunk for me as
under the Red Hood and as uh and his Flashpoint
Paradox so I enjoyed the action I enjoyed
like you said the the arrow the points that
all coming together and I liked the characters
we did have time with like we got to meet
Victor and Cyborg so he was a highlight we
got to meet Barry and Flash he was a highlight
we got we didn't get Bruce but we got such
a good Batman I was really impressed with
this Batman because I I've said and it's gotten
me yelled at by all sorts of DC fans that
the Batman Dynamic has to be difference between
uh the the Matt Reeves Batman which I mentioned
earlier and Bruce Wayne versus Batman Batman's
effectively three characters there's Batman
there's the public Bruce Wayne and there's
the private Bruce Wayne which is why I'm such
a fan of what Christian Bale did because sure
he played three characters he's not playing
two he's playing three so I really like that
we have those three characters in uh the comic
books but we don't have those in the Matt
Reeves movie because they he hasn't developed
his third character yet yeah he doesn't even
care about that right now yeah he doesn't
like Bruce Wayne doesn't and that was lot
of people's criticism with the Matt Reeves
Batman was Bruce Wayne was barely in it and
I was like that's the point is is he is Batman
the mask is Bruce but Bruce hasn't developed
the mask yet so we just developed so badly
not to be bruised so why would he develop
the Playboy Persona when he doesn't even care
about the shell of Bruce so this is a more
Dynamic way to make the Batman here work with
these gods and realize how ridiculous this
job is but that humor is so important so they
nailed the humor they nailed the way he fights
they nailed the smarts and all those things
so I loved this Batman like there's a lot
of positives like if this was a Batman story
that had these characters as elswirls that
he's interacting with and he's like why is
Diana so weird yeah I'd love that like that
all worked for me and Billy Batson like I
I thought the stealing of the the Jersey was
genius like I really enjoyed their Dynamic
a lot uh and then the like the team up at
the end like a lot works for me I don't want
to I don't want to sound negative but to me
it was like we just got out of I think two
of the best animated movies ever yeah so I'm
really excited for the next one because because
you were saying like the next one like a lot
of people like and leading into this next
series so um yeah I dug it but I am excited
for the next one more yeah and I didn't even
realize that's uh that's the thing is it's
I I'm hoping to hone my ear for the voices
because each time we come into this I'm like
okay who is and I feel like I'm gonna miss
an anvil and I get to the end credits and
be like oh of course but uh freaking Matt
O'Mara like he's got the Dual cred because
I know him from Agents of Shield and the MC
kind of you and now it's over and now doing
Batman here like I loved his take on the character
yeah I really liked his Batman I I don't know
that actor so I'll look him up that is a solid
Batman yeah and Michelle monaghan's Wonder
Woman is probably my favorite oh sure well
and I hope to hear I hope she does more Wonder
Woman because it would be nice to you know
hearing especially that perspective and again
kind of having her be one of the more obvious
tone-shifted characters I would love to hear
Michelle monaghan's take on a more classic
Wonder Woman and two with Superman it does
I I have started to very much sort of cherish
and and appreciate when I find an interpretation
that does seem like it it is whoever's writing
it isn't feeling encumbered by the tenets
of the character well that's what's so hard
is he's a lot like Captain America where it's
like on paper how do you make this guy interesting
like how do you make this character that's
why I was so impressed Chris Evans take because
he made a very impossible character fascinating
then Winter Soldier leveled it up to a 20.
but Superman is I think one of the hardest
characters to write and that's why there's
so few comic runs I'd recommend and that's
why I always wonder if I'm wrong because they're
so you know I mean he's been around for 70
years I'm like I like these 30 like they're
so funny that's still a lot no I'm not even
saying 30 years like 30 runs like like that's
still a lot still a lot that's fair but like
in the that was here I was over here like
what if five or six there's five issues kid
this is Superman this is the only good guys
uh I know I'm in the minority here but one
issue with Superman really gets them uh but
yeah it's hard to uh it's hard to feel like
you know what the character is when a lot
of people do see him more aggressively and
I just feel like that's fundamentally not
how he's perceived if that's Superman but
I'm curious what the next film's interpretation
especially of these two that I'm flummoxed
by I'm really excited to see more cyborg now
that he gets through the heart with some screen
time yeah I wanted more flash I get why we
got limited time because they were sharing
with Barry um Shazam being part of the Justice
League makes me so happy because if we don't
get to see that very much and now Aquaman
it looks like with that post credit scene
yeah I'm really excited for the next one and
and okay and the post credit scene the king
is dead that's not Aquaman himself no it must
be um like I was like where's Aquaman this
feels like someone's missing we got to the
end and then I was like oh yeah when when
they had yeah like right when that Big C Spire
was disappearing when they had won I was like
oh yeah like she's got to be going wild in
the oceans right they dropped a lot of stuff
and those numbers Cuts there we never acknowledge
Aquaman and he's like one of the quintessential
Justice League it's not a complaint and obviously
they did it for a reason but but yeah I'm
like where where's Aqua Mission it's like
a thing we missed man and I'm curious which
take he is sure and like this seems to be
a going universe so what's he gonna be like
yeah and and and two if the next take even
you know is consistent with these things yeah
does this continue uh audience let us know
which of these characters you feel like are
the most accurate to your interpretation like
I said archetypal let us know uh which of
these movies you enjoy the most let us know
if you feel like we were spot on or if you're
gonna yell at me about my thoughts on Superman
and Wonder Woman because it's coming uh but
please please please no matter what do comment
do like do subscribe hit that notification
Bell we are gonna do more of these but we
need you to like subscribe share if you want
to see more of these because that's how the
internet works so please do all of that and
uh patrons hope you enjoyed your sink to sync
Line to Line watching it with us in HBO Max
right John I love doing this week man I love
doing this with you real fun I'm excited from
trees I am too oh 2023 hanging out dude I'm
looking forward to it I love that you guys
are looking for it seems like everyone's been
pretty popular I was I actually read the comments
didn't didn't break me didn't cry once not
nope not even a little bit I didn't have to
well dude in the spirit of love let's end
this video off with a with a patron of the
day shout out
Lance door you're the Superman of this Channel
and you know what you would be the iconic
definitive interpretation you're a good dude
you're a stand-up dude but you know how to
get stuff done does Superman ever quip uh
like he ever he doesn't quip in the traditional
sense but he'll say something that is so like
Earnest and sincere it comes across as it
does that make sense like he'll say something
and you're like oh where that it's funny but
he might not even realize it or everyone else
is like if that's so Superman like that kind
of Quip dude that's that's the Lance door
humor that I feel like you would have you
would show up kick open a door douse a fire
say something kind to the kid and then the
kid's like hey you got jokes Lance doors yes
that's I guess that's what I'm hoping in 2023
get funnier Lance come on you got a great
name Lance that's all I know about you yeah
good name Lance real strong yeah the two syllables
but like with them oomph there like Lance
door yeah he's got some yeah if a guy kicked
down a door and was like Lance doors I don't
know why it's always a door like an 80s action
now he's in these action started my mind dude
yeah yeah tear those sleeves off and you know
cover yourself with some baby oil oil off
Lance door or Lambo makeup proud of you love
you buddy hope your 2023 is off to a good
start and we'll see you next month we'll see
you for the next one of these animated movies
we're excited about and trailers and stuff
you know you know what you're doing here you're
an hour and a half into a video you know you
know where you're at all right bye rejects
I love you [Music]